what's going so horribly wrong for a
niche today
he just didn't look confident he was
slow he wasn't playing aggressively
against magnus especially when magnus
isn't 100 healthy you have to be
aggressive
because he had that you could beat him
because he had that perfect opportunity
in game one didn't he but he got the
perfect opening to be aggressive and
instead he swapped everything off and
offered a draw and i think that was as
you mentioned at the time david he was
he said he was very happy
but that was a terrible mistake i mean
that was the golden opportunity in game
one to go for a win and go for checkmate
literally just go for the kill
um so very strange turning point already
in game one but that's when the momentum
switched purely to magnus that's when
magnus realized gary was afraid of him
so a few checks there from white the
black king though finding a safe square
and
a queen coming on the board next move
nothing else to be done gary is about to
throw in the towel and resign
it's over
magnus carlsen wins the match against
initially in three games gaining all
three points